[Music]
foreign
here is a list of the nine biggest
werewolves from movies each of them
different in design from the other but
eerily similar because they are all
Lycan tropes so let's get to it and
number nine we have the werewolf from
Cabin in the Woods the werewolf is the
first Master of the characters see when
they enter the facilities lift holding
area in the movie Cabin in the Woods the
werewolf then lashes out at them through
the glass startling them the werewolf is
described in the same stereotypical way
as all the others it stands tall and was
very intimidating and has fur that is
gray in color the werewolf appears to be
much taller than an average human
stunning around seven or eight feet tall
giving him greater strength agility and
speed furthermore the werewolf appears
to be stuck in a transformation phase
and cannot turn back into a human number
eight we have David Gessler the American
Werewolf in London so he here David
Kessler is an American Backpacker who
along with his friend is traveling
across England while they were walking
on the Moors at 9 night they were
attacked by a werewolf Jack his friends
killed but David Kessler survives though
he sustained serious injuries David
wakes up later in a hospital in London
and starts experiencing strange vivid
dreams and hallucinations he also begins
to realize that he is turning into a
werewolf himself and as the full moon
approaches David transforms into a
bloodthirsty wolf that is around 2.4
meters or 8 feet tall and is hell bent
on killing innocent people
number seven the skinwalker from blood
moon in death 2021 Blood Moon movie a
small town is terrorized by a mysterious
creature that is rumored to be a
skinwalker the skinwalker is a
shape-shifter from Navajo mythology that
can transform into any animal it Desires
in the movie the skinwalker takes the
form of a wolf-like creature which is
also humanoid in design with glowing
eyes and razor sharp claws it is
revealed that the skinwalker was once a
human who made a deal with a
supernatural being for immortality and
power so the skinwalker in blood moon is
depicted as a vengeful and malevolent
force that must prey on humans to
fulfill that deal
number six the werewolves from love
death and robots seen in the episode
called shape shifters from the Anthology
series called love death and robots
there were two werewolves that are
soldiers working for the Taliban
secretly plotting to bring the U.S
Marines there to their knees in a world
where werewolves are common but still
feared and mistrusted these werewolves
are fast furious and highly intelligent
even in their beastial forms which is
roughly more than eight feet or close to
nine feet maybe somewhere there 8.5 feet
tall however there was another third
werewolf from the U.S cam who actually
defeated the two and was fighting to
save the US base
number five The Wolfman from dark
soldiers these are the primary
antagonists in the movie called Dark
soldiers in their Lupine form werewolves
resemble Lupine humanoids with gray hair
and brownish skin standing by peterly at
roughly nine feet tall they possess
heads strongly resembling those of gray
wolves and shape and fur color with
bright green eyes they are vicious
predators that can prey on humans and
despite their be still nature they are
still cunning and half a pack mentality
if a human is scratched by the claws of
a werewolf that was transformed and
survives long enough which means he
didn't die in the attack that human will
transform into another werewolf himself
number four William corvines from
Underworld Evolution William corvinus is
the son of Alexander corvinus a powerful
Immortal who is the Genesis of vampires
and werewolves William was born as a
human but he possessed a rare genetic
mutation that allows him to transform
into a pure werewolf this trait was
passed down to his descendants resulting
in the birth of the first lichen William
is portrayed as a vicious and Savage
creature who is feared by both vampires
and humans and also by his descending
lichens in his were will form his nearly
Invincible he is also shown to have a
strong bond with his fellow lichens and
is regarded as their god-like figure he
is Stalin and other lichens being 2.7
meters or nine feet tall
number three The Shape Shifters from
Twilight in the Twilight series
shapeshifters are members of the
quirulative tribe a Native American
tribe in Washington of the U.S of a they
can transform to Giant nine feet long
wolves excluding their tails which are
much larger and stronger than regular
wolves they can transform into Worlds
whenever they want to rather than just
being transformed at Full Moon
furthermore they are not affected by
silver and are resistant to most forms
of injury in the Twilight films the
shapeshifters have a long-standing
rivalry with vampires the clan of the
Cullens believing that the vampires
posed a threat to their tribe and way of
life however in order to protect their
home and loved ones from a common enemy
they eventually form an uneasy Alliance
and then friendship with that clan of
vampires
number two Gabriel Van Helsing in the
2004 movie Van Helsing Gabriel which is
Gabriel Van Helsing in its true form is
actually a powerful Archangel he
possesses incredible destructive power
capable of leveling entire series but
however he here is a moral and Powerless
since he is inhabiting a living human
flesh due to some unknown reason in his
past experiences Gabriel turned into a
werewolf that was actually immune to the
mind control of Count Dracula later in
the movie he appeared as a giant nine
feet or 2.7 meter tall wolf humanoid who
had black fur and deadly fangs and with
these Powers he eventually killed the
Demonic Count Dracula and number one the
biggest werewolf here in this list the
super lichen from Underworld Awakening
super lichens are larger and more
muscular than regular lichens with
thicker fur and longer claws but they
don't live long they also have enhance
abilities such as increased strength
Speed and Agility as well as ability to
heal from all injuries very quickly
Quint Lane the son of Dr Jacob Lane is
the main super lichen character in the
underworld Awakening movie and he
becomes the first successful subject of
the Lichen Evolution process due to the
developed serum he used on himself the
superliken that he transformed into grew
to be over 3.5 meters or 12 feet in
height and therefore the biggest in this
list so I hope you have enjoyed watching
this video do hit the like button for
support and subscribe but most of all
smash that Bell icon for regular updates
on new videos right here on this channel
till the next one take care fam